so
imkto3
from Colombia
so now
the moragam please I
have no idea at all, yes I often
just
reacted with D3
and said okay, go ahead, I
really don't know what I'm doing, but
maybe if you just had
an idea,
do it like that, no  I have to play six
games anyway, it wasn't exactly what I wanted,
man oh man oh man oh, why did
n't I think about it for a second, I
thought it was already running out,
but let's see how
we can get this to be
halfway saved here
so that it can open up for me  Bishop F4 Spinner
E5 play yes you have to give up another move with A6
than this great move
well
on B5 he will 100% sacrifice something
so
yes it is dangerous now really
dangerous if he plays that right away
and C6 goes Knight B5 too
well maybe I can here too
and anyway then bishop B6
I mean
eight is easy oh what a shame oh what a
shame
god oh god oh god
what of you was sitting there
yes
help with that C6 I can't play
Tom the eight chess king E7  and with that
B4 and congratulations on checkmate I have to
go here and now he can just do
the eight games, at least he can
go to the games, maybe even completely different
things,
yes he wins but he would just have to do
B6 and again do one thing to you God
oh God oh  God help,
yes, you can only complain but it does
n't help, please
open it once, like
Mora then please lose somehow, yes
then you have to worry,
so
God, I'm breaking down, he lets me play
runners for five games,
oh God, what a one  crazy games
more
God oh God oh God well
some games
I have to
get back to normal here somehow, what a
mistake,
yes I hope that I'm not just
doing some kind of exploitation nonsense,
so today they're actually here to
give the jellyfish back
so that nothing really happens here
Now with the eternal knight on it E5
it actually looks very safe
so D6 now covers B7 comfortably
then you should actually have
the opportunity
to collect more pawns here right now,
well he doesn't give up
which you can understand a bit after the opening
because
I played that really well,
so now that there's no passing pawn left,
it should actually
be relatively simple now. I'm
beginning to believe that
somehow he doesn't want it,
no glory hand for both of them, no, the
opening was of course great, so I didn't
see it  After that you feel really
terrible
and then he just stopped the lady from
believing it